break up
as a continuation of the black ops sub
series call of duty black ops for both
benefits from and is limited by its past
all three of its major modes multiplayer
zombies in the new battle royale mode
black out whole from and build upon
previous games multiplayer is largely
successful in its mix of old and new
while zombies struggles with more dated
elements black out those strikes an
excellent balance putting a clever Call
of Duty spin on a genre entirely new to
the series I'm thinking bigger than
battles and Wars I brought you here to
change the world what do you have in
mind
while black ops 4 doesn't have a
traditional single-player campaign it
does have a helpful set of character
focused tutorial missions called
specialist HQ it introduces you to each
of the 10 multiplayer specialists one by
one taking you through their unique
abilities and a practice multiplayer
match it has a bit of a story and some
gorgeous and gory cutscenes starting
each mission together
but mainly it's there to get you
acquainted with the new specialist
mechanics
it also weaves in a bit of zombies
training and unexpected but welcome
touch that helps make the largely
separate modes feel a little more
cohesive
[Music]
with the standard multiplayer black ops
4 takes a more tactical approach than
previous games as promised there's no
wall running your Thresh jumping
movement is weighty and grounded the
biggest change though is that healing is
now manual and on a cooldown timer this
forces you to be more thoughtful about
your positioning since you can't just
jet and dodge enemy fire until your
health regenerates you need to make sure
you have adequate cover and time to heal
yourself in your immediate vicinity all
this encourages they slightly slower
more cautious pace individually overall
time to kill is still low which ensures
matches don't stagnate each specialist
has a unique weapon and equipment with a
specific combat focus like area control
or high damage output certain
specialists and strategies are more
useful in some game types than others
area control is best for objective based
modes like domination for example but
generally your choice of specialists in
your team's composition won't matter if
you aren't skilled in basic shooting and
positioning this means you can play
selfishly and still have a good time
which works well for those of us who
often solo queue and would rather not
risk trying to communicate with randoms
but it can also make playing support
focus specialists less rewarding if you
aren't working as a team since your
efforts are useless if your teammates
don't take advantage of them it's a
surprisingly good balance overall though
giving you the flexibility to only be as
tactical as you want or able to be and
enjoy the match regardless
[Applause]
the always over-the-top zombies mode is
as broad as it is deep with two separate
storylines across three maps for if you
have the black ops pass included in the
game special editions the first two nine
and voyage of despair are part of the
brand-new chaos story a lot of the dead
and classified round out the selection
of maps to make up the returning either
story the chaos maps are strong
aesthetically with rich level design and
clever puzzles to match draining water
that has seeped into Titanic's depth so
you don't drown while searching for
other secrets for example the reimagined
ether maps have familiar layouts and
puzzles but there are enough differences
from the original maps to surprise
returning players however the Ultima
screw hasn't aged particularly well even
considering that each of them is
stereotyped to the extreme the jokes
just don't land anymore especially
Tokyo's overdone Japanese accent where
ELLs are replaced with ours at every
opportunity in blood of the dead it's
distracting but in classified lines
about the Emperor and eating sushi
border unoffensive you'll also hear
these same lines every time you start a
new run which doesn't help on top of the
already hefty amount of zombies content
black ops 4 introduces a new mode of
fighting the undead rush it's a much
faster paced version of zombies where
you don't have to do any thinking or
puzzle solving you're just there to kill
the undead horde style there's no money
so you don't need to save up to buy a
weapon or unlock a door you're instead
told which area will have the next rush
wave and you're directed from room to
room as you go it's too intense to be a
tutorial per se but it's a great way to
familiarize yourself but map test
weapons and plan where to go next if you
get stuck in classic mode
the third and arguably most exciting of
black ops Force three main sections is
of course blackout like other Battle
Royale games Call of Duty's take puts a
hundred players on one map with the goal
of being the last person or squad
standing it's unlike anything Call of
Duty has ever done before and slight
alterations to its mechanics like the
addition of bullet drop help it adapt
the single map is filled with references
to previous games broken up into
distinct and memorable regions like in
other battle royale games positioning in
situational awareness are critical and
the easy to navigate map design
facilitates strategic movement
brilliantly experience in both
multiplayer and zombies benefits you in
blackout perks and specialist equipment
can be looted during a match and knowing
how to both use and counter them can
give you a huge advantage
there are also zombie infested areas
that offer powerful loot at the risk of
attracting human players to your
position and that PvE twist in
particular helps distinguish blackout
from the likes of pub G the combination
of these Call of Duty specific mechanics
with pub G style health loot and
shooting systems is executed well with
quality of life improvements in the UI
and on the technical side most
importantly it successfully captures the
tense shaky excitement that makes battle
royale such a popular genre ops 4 isn't
short on content and it's three main
modes are substantial multiplayer
introduces more tactical mechanics
without forcing you into them and it
largely strikes a good balance zombies
has multiple deep secret filled Maps to
explore though it's returning characters
don't hold up and prove distracting
finally blackout pushes Call of Duty in
an entirely new direction making use of
aspects from both multiplayer and
zombies for a take on the Battle Royale
genre that stands on its own sure there
isn't a traditional single-player
campaign but black ops 4 doesn't need it
what is there has the depth and breadth
to be great on its own
[Music]
you
[Music]